In 2009, a mysterious person or persons who
went under the name Satoshi Nakamoto wrote
a piece of software that would become the
foundation of a new kind of money: cryptocurrency.
For a while, bitcoin and its brethren was
just a hobby for computer programmers and
math nerds, but recently, it’s drawn the
interest of investors, banks and governments
who wonder if it might actually start competing
with traditional currencies like dollars and
yen.
Bitcoin’s been in the news a lot lately,
but if you’re like most people, you’ve
probably never used it, and don’t know exactly
what it is.
But according to some estimates,
over 16 million Americans buy and sell bitcoin
frequently, and over 100,000 merchants and
vendors worldwide accept it as payment.
But is that enough to qualify as a currency?
And should you be getting on the crypto-bandwagon
before it’s too late?
In a previous episode, we talked about how
money is based on trust.
You trust that this dollar has value because
your government says it does.
You trust your bank when they tell you how
much money is in your account.
But cryptocurrency is unique in that there
are no centralized powers--no governments,
no banks--to enforce its value or track its
accounting.
Instead, every single bitcoin transaction
is added to an encrypted ledger called a “blockchain,”
that is shared publicly on thousands of computers
all over the world.
Updating this blockchain involves solving
a special math problem and takes a lot of
computer power.
Bitcoin “miners’” who create and update
the blockchain and are rewarded for their
work with shiny new bitcoins, each imprinted
with the whole history of bitcoin transactions
since the blockchain began.
It’s as if this dollar bill had a written
record on it of everywhere it’s ever been--and
everywhere every other dollar bill has ever
been.
No one can counterfeit bitcoin because everyone
knows exactly how much everyone else is supposed
to have.
Your bitcoin “wallet,” doesn’t really
hold bitcoins, it’s just an encrypted key
that gives you access to however many bitcoins
the blockchain says you have.
Which means that, unlike a bank that will
give you a new debit card if you lose yours,
there’s no way to retrieve a lost key.
One man in the U.K. mistakenly threw away
the hard drive that had his key on it, and
his $100 million worth of bitcoins are permanently
trapped in cyberspace limbo, inaccessible
to anyone ever.
Bummer.
Bitcoin’s not highly regulated, and that’s
made it the go-to currency for shall we say,
less-than-savory activities.
Drugs, prostitution, and other black-market
items are regularly paid for in bitcoins because
of the pseudo-anonymity it provides.
According to a study at the University of
Sydney, nearly half of all Bitcoin transactions
are used for illegal activities.
And new cryptocurrencies like Monero are growing
in popularity as they claim to be completely
anonymous.
But there are other reasons why bitcoin hasn’t
gone mainstream.
As you’ve probably heard in the news recently,
it’s really volatile.
Just in the past couple years, the price of
one bitcoin has gone from around $500 to almost
$20,000, then back down to around $7,000.
So even if your local coffee shop wanted to
accept Bitcoin, they’d have to be constantly
updating the menu board prices.
And because it can take pretty long to update
the blockchain, your latte will probably be
cold by the time you get it.
So, if bitcoin isn’t really feasible as
a mainstream currency just yet… why is everyone
talking about it?
Well, most people are interested in bitcoin
not as a currency, but a speculative investment.
Just like gold, tulips or beanie babies, any
resource that fluctuates wildly in price will
attract people who want to get rich quick.
And some people do.
But speculative investing is ultra-risky.
Unlike a rental property or a successful business,
bitcoin has no intrinsic value.
It’s a pure gamble, hoping that you can
buy the thing from one sucker and sell it
to an even bigger sucker for more money.
And even though the number of Bitcoins is
finite--the original programmers coded in
a hard limit of 21 million--new crypto-currencies
using blockchain are popping up every day.
Maybe Monero, ZCash or Ethereum will ultimately
overtake Bitcoin as the most popular cryptocurrency.
Some experts even believe that crypto might
become adopted by governments some day.
So, if you’re thinking about investing in
bitcoin, you should ask yourself the same
things any speculative investor would: Do
I really understand what I’m buying, and
can I afford to lose my entire investment?
If the answer to either question is no, it’s
probably best to steer clear.
Maybe someday we’ll be using cryptocurrency
to rent hoverboards on Mars, but today, it’s
popularity is based more on its potential
than its practicality.
Unless you’re an international criminal,
in which case… cut it out.
And that’s our two cents!